have you been watching the johnny depp
and amber heard thing the most i've
tapped into is a series of dad jokes on
reddit that should not be funny i mean
the obvious is amber turd yeah i love
that one yeah it's not a dad joke that's
good old-fashioned just a good joke
that's good old-fashioned humor so i was
reading about how she left the piece of
[ __ ] on his bed one of the comments was
uh
he's had enough of her [ __ ] already and
i don't know why that
just killed me yeah and then someone
said uh hashtag meepoo and that's not
that shouldn't yeah it shouldn't it
shouldn't it shouldn't it shouldn't i
don't know it's like a relatively
complex case i mean there's just like
layers to it right and like
like devastation on both sides like he
like lost his career and she i guess is
lying i don't really know right but the
whole thing that anyone can focus on is
the fact that she's [ __ ] in his [ __ ]
bed yeah she lost a turd burger dude
yeah i really i was like captivated by
this [ __ ] i don't know like seeing
him on the stand do anything yeah is
cool do you know what i'm saying i don't
know i don't know who's gonna win this
you know that's up to the jury
right now it looks like she's like
[ __ ] lying for sure
but uh you know i'm just watching it
like he's so like eloquent but not
really
just he's like an artist so you can just
tell this is that voice i watched him
for like an hour before they even turned
the sound on on the broadcast
before they even they even started the
the
courtroom it was just him sitting there
on the stand for an hour and you were
tapped in a tap down how did it watch
that you won't watch batman
meant to tell you
i watched
about a quarter of it last night we're
gonna get into it we're gonna
get into it we're gonna get into it
i watched a lot of the [ __ ] that he was
actually saying yesterday i saw it it
started because it's like on every day
it's right now too it's on every day all
day why do they broadcast these things
i mean it's him i just feel like it's
such a high profile case you're like
this dude like don't you think all the
social media and everything could sway
the
jurors i mean you know his agent
probably worked it out i mean he hasn't
done a movie in a while so this would
probably be good too
i think it will be oh yeah i think this
[ __ ] is gonna get cast in
everything after this i think he's going
to get casted in the remake of the whole
of the of the story yeah you get the
plan and he plays amber heard yeah yeah
yeah you know [ __ ] in what was
supposed to be my own bed was a
traumatic scene for me going through the
other side i think it was cathartic
i mean nah dude that
i i don't even know what's going i just
know that she's a bad person and she's
hit him a few times yeah but that's all
i know that's what it sounds like i read
something about how the whole
compilation of the lawyer being like
hearsay hearsay it's pretty common
ah
yeah he also objected to his own
question which was pretty [ __ ]
awesome it asks a question and then the
judge says something he goes objection
and she's like you asked the question
he's like oh right right sorry
my man
i mean that's you know he's sick of the
[ __ ] yeah exactly
he's just playing mind games which is
the same thing you gotta do when someone
asks you for a picture i get a picture
can i get a picture objection
objection here say objection here say
can i take a selfie can i take a selfie
of me can i take a picture of you on
your phone
sure
you look great can you get a picture of
me on my phone i won't tell anyone i
won't tell anyone you took this i don't
want to be glib if she's like a bad
person it's definitely um it's really
cool that johnny's back on tv yeah
it worked for me dude i'm telling you
i'm sitting there like god everything
this guy says it's like you can tell why
he's such a
revered actor because he's just good at
talking he's just good at talking yeah
which i don't know that i feel like that
also kind of like sways the like it just
makes it easier for you to believe him
you know yeah that's his [ __ ] career
yeah yeah do we have any do you have any
clips a few things about coachella then
the
fecal
delivery
and saying saying that it was the dogs
and i i i'm sorry i could not agree with
her i'd lived with those dogs i picked
up their fun it was not the dogs
[Laughter]
they're fun it's the it's the words he
chooses exactly right yeah he doesn't
say like he doesn't speak like a regular
person yeah yeah i've been and every
text he sends is just [ __ ] absurd
yeah filled with exclamation marks and
he's like i don't know talking to his
assistant or whatever and he's like
brett my darling so it's really cool
that uh you know everyone's pointing out
that
they're just sexualizing the [ __ ] out of
him well he's on trial for abuse yeah no
he's on tr no this isn't for abu this is
defamation oh she's suing him he's suing
her he's suing her yes got it because
he's like it's not true what you said
about me oh i would do this she she
accused him of of abuse okay so he lost
captain jack sparrow he lost all of his
movie roles all right basically hit the
[ __ ] yeah and he was like it's not
true basically what happened was you
took a whole bunch of videos of me in
order to make this case and make it seem
like i was abusing you when really you
were abusing me the whole time
and i lost my career because of it i
think that's what right that's the gist
yeah yeah she's also counter-suing him
for 100 million dollars counter suing
for what
the same thing of defamation just kind
of going back and forth with it he
defecation
nice dude
that's good
that was good did i read that right you
did and then she writes
my throat is yours you're going to be
the death of me
but i don't care and then you write i
have other uses for your throat which do
not include
injury
i have other uses for your throat which
do not include injury
sorry did you read that again
is your word sir right i read that right
correct
you did yes
you can take that down
i have other uses for your throat you
just [ __ ]
that's right
just repeat his sentence just pretend
you're the guy reading this [ __ ]
and then you said
i have other uses for your throat
[Laughter]
could you read that again sure and then
you said
i have other uses for your throat
[Laughter]
just going in
the judge is like
uh
recess
recess jesus christ all the tick tock
clips yeah naughty johnny
johnny like that's this one is like
naughty johnny that's what this is
literally a [ __ ] courtroom it's a
courtroom what are you doing naughty
johnny yeah but it's johnny being
naughty that's johnny so [ __ ] hot
slay me johnny
that's how that's crazy that's sued for
a hundred million dollars no that that's
how much sex appeal this dude has he
could be in literally the driest
environment yeah he's got that [ __ ] yeah
wet yeah
gushing this is so [ __ ] hot to get
sued
when johnny depp says i have other uses
for your throat that do not include
injury what is that what is this
music music maybe just play it silently
yeah which is a shame because i love
that voice and johnny says it's just
a bunch of
i volunteer as tribute tears tribute
nice nice dude a hunger games reference
sick
nice job whatever millennial wrote that
[ __ ]
yeah seriously good meme dude bring up
his emails and texts real quick oh oh
are these like the violent ones
i don't know well it's not fun anymore
now is it he did say some crazy [ __ ] do
you know any of it off the top of your
head i mean like he wrote to his friend
and was like i don't know like basically
like called her a [ __ ] hope that she
like wakes up in a ditch or something
like that
something i'm paraphrasing but uh
objection
[Laughter]
hearsay let's drown her before we burn
her
whoa
yeah i don't know here's her burnt
corpse afterwards to make sure she's
dead no he's just preparing for his role
as the villain and joan of arc that's
all right yeah right this method